（メジャーで計測中）
ススッ、ズーーーーーーーｗｗｗ
（メジャー伸ばし中）
ｼｭｰｰｰｰｯ
は）あっ、きた
は）ここです
は）ここでぴったり50ｍ
は）ﾊﾟﾝｯ（手をたたく音）
2人）・・・・・・。
マ）ふふふｗｗｗ
（3人バラバラ・・・）
は）えっ？？ちょちょ、そこは揃わない？ｗ
3人）スポーツの秋～
は）こんにちは！はじめしゃちょーと！
割愛☆（＾＾）
は）まあ！秋といえば！間違いなく、
は）スポーツと読書、この２つしかもう無いですね。
は）スポーツを最近してないんですけども
は）ちょっとやっぱりね、いつもこもってるだけじゃなくてね
は）なんかこう、定期的にね！
は）スポーツの動画を出していきたいと思ってるんで。
は）もうハンドボール投げしたじゃんね
は）ね、秋なんでちょっとね今回は
は）スポーツを！やっていこうと思いまして。
は）今日は！
は）50ｍ走でぇすっ！！よっ！
（拍手）ﾊﾟﾁﾊﾟﾁﾊﾟﾁﾊﾟﾁ
は）スポーツテストとかでもさぁ
は）競技になってるからさぁ
は）気になるわけじゃないですか、タイムが。
？？？？？？ｗｗｗ
は）果たして僕は今どのくらいのタイムなのかをね、
は）ちょっとここ２人とね、比較しながら、
は）見ていこうと思います。
は）では、行こうっ！
は）ベネズエラ出身のマサキ選手です。
は）今回の大会の意気込みは？
マ）意気込み･･･
マ）ﾌｨｯｯ
マ）はいｗ
は）さあ、まもなくキックオフです。
の）よーーーいっ
の）ドンッ！！
は・実況）きました。さあ、きましたよ。
は）おぉ、でも！
は）え、でもよかったよ、多分！
マ）ほんとー？　は）うん
は）記録
（単位を間違えるはじめしゃちょーｗ）
２人）ｗｗｗｗｗ
マ）ﾊﾟﾁﾊﾟﾁﾊﾟﾁ　は）早いんじゃない？
マ）まあまあだよね？　は）まあまあだよね、多分。
は）次の選手はこちらです。
は）のりくん！
は）就職先がなく困っている、
大学４年生の選手でございますｗｗ
は）さあ、今回の大会の意気込みは？
の）いやぁ、やっぱ(笑)
の）フォースTシャツ着てるんで、
の）やっぱ一瞬ですよｗ
の）はい・・・ｗ
の）こうやって・・・
（静かにフレームアウト・・・）
（曇天）
マ）位置について、よーーーい
マ）ドンッ！
は・実況）はじまりました。
は・実況）お、早い早い
は・実況）いいペースです。時間もちゃんと計ってます。
の）ﾝﾝﾝｳｦｵｵｵｵｯﾎｵｵｗｗｗｗﾎｵｵｵｵｗｗｗ（叫）
は）きましたーーーーーっ！
は）この就職難とは思えない表情。
の）うおぉぉぉ！
の）3番手！はじめしゃちょー（ダミ声）
は）よぉし
の）手足が長いことを活かしどれだけ早く走れるかが
ポイントですね。
は）君たち7秒台っしょ？
2人）7秒台です･･･
は）話にならん
は）俺は6秒目指すからなぁ！
は）よしっ、行こう！
の）えっ、うわぁっはっ待ってwww
の）えっ？
の）下駄！？
の）やっぱ違いますね王はｗ
の）下駄で走るらしいっすねｗ
の）せっかく靴買ったのに･･･
の）多分気づいてないんだと思うww
マ）だ、大丈夫だってｗｗｗ
マ）よーーーーい
マ）ドンッ！
（下駄で走るはじめしゃちょー）
下駄）ﾍﾟｯﾀｯﾍﾟｯﾀｯﾍﾟｯﾀｯﾍﾟｯﾀｯwwwwwwwwww
シャキーーーーン☆（効果音）
マ）記録は
・・・・・・・・。
は）♪とぅっとぅっとぅーとぅっとぅっとぅーとぅるるるるっ♪
は）♪とぅっとぅっとぅ♪ ｗｗｗｗ
は）あーいいよーいいよーｗ
マ）う”わぁ#%&#%???(叫)
は）抜いたー！！どうだっ
は）顔顔顔ｗｗｗ
は）顔顔ｗｗｗ
は）え？遅ない？
は）めっちゃ遅いやん、マサキｗｗｗ
マ）ドンッ！
は）♪とぅっとぅっとぅーとぅっとぅっとぅーとぅるるるるっ♪
は）あ、早い早い
の）ん”ん”ん”ぁあああああ！(叫）
の）う”わぁああああ(叫)
は）顔、顔が動いてない
は）おわーーーーイッターーーーー！
マ）ぐふんｗｗ///
は）空間光学手ブレ補正みたいに顔だけ動いてなかったよ
の）んふふｗｗ
の）おぉーーーーおｗ
の）はぁはぁ（息切れ）
3人）なんともいえない･･･ｗ
は）次はもう靴履くからね
は）どうなっても知らないから
の）そしてつい、30分くらい前に買った
の）派手な靴を(笑)
は）よしこぉぉぉぉぉおおおい！！(叫）
マ）よーーーい
マ）ドンッ！
ﾌﾞﾛﾛﾛﾛﾛﾛﾛﾛﾛ（車の音）
は）んうぇぇ”ぇ”ぇ”っ(叫)
マ）いい記録出ましたね。
の）出ましたか！
マ）よーーーい
マ）ドンッ
の）うわぁ
の）うおぉぉぉ
の）待てぇええ
の）待て待て
の）待て待てぇｗ
2人）う”ぅぉぉぉおおお
2人）う”ぅぇ”ぇ”ぇ”（嗚咽）　ｯｹﾞｯﾎ
は）なんか徐々に遅くなってるよねｗ
ま）GODはじめーん選手
は）たっ、頼むよ頼む頼むっ
は）うわああああああああ！
は）もうちょっとじゃん！
ま）あと、0.09秒
は）え、イケる気がしてきた
マ）位置について
マ）よーーーい
マ）ドンッ！
は）う”わぁぁぁっはぁぁ！！(叫)
（若干鼻で笑うマサキ）
マ）結果は・・・
ﾄﾞｳﾙﾙﾙﾙﾙﾙﾙﾙﾙﾙﾙﾙﾙﾙﾙﾙﾙﾙﾙﾙﾙﾙﾙﾙﾙﾙﾙﾙﾙﾙ
（ドラムロール）
は）もう無理
♪エンディング♪
マ）ドンッ！
は）あっはっはｗｗｗ